Es ist eine eigentlich unmögliche Entdeckung.
Einen so alten Stern dürfte es gar nicht
geben.
Aber es gibt ihn.
Ein US-Astronomen-Team hat wohl einen der
ältesten Sterne überhaupt in unserem Kosmos
entdeckt.
Und dieser 13,5 Milliarden Jahre alter Rote
Zwerg entstand wohl nicht nur aus der ersten
Sternengeneration nach dem Urknall, sondern
liegt sogar direkt in der kosmischen Nachbarschaft
unserer Erde.
Warum das eine unmögliche Entdeckung ist
erfahrt ihr jetzt bei Clixoom Science & Fiction,
hier gibt es täglich faszinierende Science
Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts herzlich willkommen!
Am Anfang war nichts und es gab nichts und
dann war da der Urknall, ein unendlich kleiner
Punkt aus dem alles entstanden ist.
Mit der Zeit bildeten sich die ersten Atome,
Molekühle.
Sterne enstanden, Planeten und Galaxien.
Doch die ersten Sterne dieser Generation müssten
eigentlich längst ausgebrannt sein.
Doch bei diesem Exemplar ist das anders und
das stellt die bisherigen Erkenntnisse der
frühen Sternentstehung auf den Kopf.
Auf die Schliche gekommen ist das Forschungsteam
der University of Baltimore dem Uralt-Stern
mit Hilfe des Gemini South Teleskops und des
Magellan Clay Teleskops in Chile.
Der Rote Stern befindet sich im Doppelsternsystem
(den unaussprechlichen Namen haben wir unten
eingeblendet) 2MASSJ18082002-5104378 direkt
neben einem großen Stern, der Astronomie-Teams
schon vor einiger Zeit aufgefallen war.
Und zwar, weil dieser sehr arm an schweren
Elementen ist - bei Sternen ein Hinweis auf
ein extrem hohes Alter.
Doch erst jetzt gelang es, den Kleineren der
beiden Sterne - den Roten Zwerg - genauer
zu analysieren.
Und das ist wirklich verrückt: Er ist sehr
klein, verfügt über etwa 14 Prozent der
Sonnenmasse und ist extrem arm an schweren
Elementen.
Er ist nicht nur metallärmer als der größere
Stern im System, sondern gehört wohl zu den
metallärmsten Sternen überhaupt im gesamten
Kosmos.
Das alles konnte durch sein Lichtspektrum
ermittelt werden.
Das Forschungsteam selbst ist total überrascht
von dieser Entdeckung.
Denn nach ihrer Einschätzung könnte der
Rote Zwerg ein stolzes Alter von 13,5 Milliarden
Jahre haben.
So liegt die Vermutung nahe, dass der Uralt-Stern
direkt aus der allerersten Generation von
Sternen nach dem Urknall entstanden ist.
Und diese Erkenntnisse stellen unsere bisherigen
Vorstellungen über das Alter und die Entstehung
unserer Galaxie in Frage.
Denn gängigen Theorien zufolge sind Sterne,
die so kurz nach dem Urknall entstanden sind,
eher kurzlebig und könnten demnach keinesfalls
eine solch lange Zeit bis heute überdauern!
Die genaue Analyse des Roten Zwerges widerlegt
jedoch diese Annahme.
Dazu Kevin Schlaufmann, einer der beteiligten
Forscher: „Dieser Stern ist gut gealtert
– er sieht heute genauso aus wie zur Zeit
seiner Entstehung vor rund 13.5 Milliarden
Jahren.
Wenn unsere Schlussfolgerungen korrekt sind,
dann könnten einige dieser massearmen Sterne
eine Zusammensetzung haben, die der des Kosmos
direkt nach dem Urknall entspricht“ Der
Uralt-Stern ist aber auch noch in einer anderen
Hinsicht eine große Überraschung, denn er
liegt direkt in unserer Nachbarschaft.
Er kreist um das Zentrum der Milchstraße.
Diese Position des Zwerg-Sterns wertet das
US-Forschungsteam als Indiz dafür, dass auch
andere Teile unserer galaktischen Umgebung
älter sein müssen als wir bisher annehmen.
Zudem weckt der Sensations-Fund die Hoffnung,
zeitnah die lang gesuchten Sterne der ersten
Generation aufzuspüren.
Modellen zufolge sind diese aus der Ur-Materie
entstanden, die vom Urknall stammt.
Die Entstehung dieser Sterne der ersten Generation
hat das Universum und seine Evolution extrem
beeinflusst Denn in ihrem Inneren haben sich
dann wohl alle schweren Elemente gebildet,
die notwendig für das Leben sind.
Beispielsweise Eisen, Sauerstoff, Stickstoff
und Kohlenstoff.
Erst dadurch konnten sich Planetensystem wie
das unsrige bilden und entwickeln.
Doch noch sind diese wirklich allerersten
Sterne oder Überreste von ihnen noch nicht
gefunden worden.
Sie müssten noch älter sein.
Mit der Entdeckung dieses roten Zwerges steigen
jetzt wieder die Hoffungen sie zu finden.
Wenn es dazu etwas neues gibt, erfahrt ihr
es natürlich hier.
Abonniert dafür am besten auch den englischen
Kanal, dann auch da gibt es immer wieder Videopremieren.
Und hier geht es weiter mit Will Alien message
endanger humanity?
Ich freue mich auf euch auf dem englischen
Kanal.
Stay tuned, see you soon.